hello everyone welcome to another
excellent game from kuda hua rapid
tournament in Abidjan and it's yummy
ponies vs. magnus carlsen really an
exciting game allowed we have requested
it already and i would just like to
thank you all already after announcing
the idea for the chest manga in the
previous video that's like an hour and a
half ago prior to making this video
already I've received over 20 emails so
be sure that we will read all of them
and whatever idea you have will be you
know carefully read and it will be
appreciated even if it may not be used
but you know I just glimpsed at some of
the emails and I already see that there
are plenty of great ideas there so thank
you all for that
and you know if you don't know what's it
all about do check out the previous
video I explained everything in the
beginning of the video I will put a link
to it in the description below so you
don't have to look for it if you're
interested but getting back to this game
and information versus Carlson called an
opponent she opens with E 4 with C 5 so
it's exciting to see whether we'll see
another clash of the World Chess
Championship preparation or will one of
them deviate from it we have Knight to
f3 Knight to c6 by Carlsen again going
for his standard setup d4c captures on
d4 Knight captures on d4 and now he 5
everything the same as in the World
Chess Championship match against Caruana
Knight B 5 and here Carlsen goes in d6
so everything the same Knight to c3 and
here cousin deviates from his World
Chess Championship
well not deviate from the preparation as
I'm sure he might have had this prepared
during the World Chess Championship but
now he goes a 6 immediately kicks away
this night and goes into this main line
of Knights to a3 with Bishop to e7 now
and we have g3 by neppo preparing to
vinca to the white square Bishop Knight
to f6 with Bishop to g2 and now b5 Magus
is preparing before to win one of the
Knights and now you could go a lot of
things but the idea behind the b5 are
not the idea but it's interesting that
in this position Bishop to g4 is the no
move
well just castling is the non move here
but b5 is a new move in this position
and it is as of now that we have a
completely new game so of course you
don't want to allow before with Knight
to d5 by nip oh and there's this
interesting line that you can choose if
you're playing bullet maybe in both you
you you will have some success with it
but it doesn't work Bishop to e3
allowing this and now going Knight to d5
and now obviously our Knight is hanging
here and after black chapters that now
you you can go for this Bishop to b6
attack the Queen but the black can allow
this now black can just go eight
characters on b2 and after the Queen is
captured just be captures on a1 bring
another queen into the game and after
captures captures you will have more
than enough compensation for the queen
with the black pieces so you know it's
not possible to go for this but it's
interesting to note that it doesn't work
but okay Knight to d5 pineapple with
Knight captures on d5e capture some d5
and now you could decide whether you
want to go here whether you want to go
here whether we want to go here and
Carson goes all the way back he wants to
remain over the night via Knight to d7
with castles by neppo and now nice to d7
as planned across and once the castle
play f5 and then decide whether this
night is coming to c5 or to f6 we have C
4 by nepo castles by crossing and now
just see capture some b5 a capture some
b5 and it's not possible to win the
point if captures then Bishop to a6 will
just be really unpleasant for black for
white as well the night is just pinned
the rook here on f1 would be captured in
the Night Moves you can't defend it
because the bishop is still undeveloped
the rook on a1 is unguarded
just captures captures and then you will
lose lose a piece here or even if you
defend it let's say Queen e2 I mean now
you only made things worse there's a
queen and rook here just Queen b8 traps
of the night and still a 4 is not
possible the bishop is undeveloped so a
nipple goes back night the c2 he wants
to remain over the night and now f5 s
plane by Carlson we have night the B for
Nepal now wants to take advantage of
this juicy c6 square and Crossin doesn't
bother blocking
with something like Bishop to v7 he
rather moves the bishop he doesn't
wanted the knight to c6 move to come
with an attack on the bishop on e7 so
Knight to c6 with Queen to eh now
getting the Queen out the way and now a4
it's a interesting move but it still
proves difficult to play because the
bishop is still undeveloped and that the
rook is still unguarded here so nipple
display a four it makes sense as you
either won't trade here or you want to
push to create a passport but Magnus
just ignores it and he goes Knight to
the c5 you still can't capture your rook
is still guarded on a1 as the bishop is
still undeveloped but what you can do is
push a five which seems like a nice idea
creating a passed pawn but maybe he was
afraid after Eve or that his Bishop
would get blocked in and then maybe
instead of having two great pawns which
would be which is a strength in the
position maybe he thought it would be a
weakness in the position and maybe it
will be too hard at to keep control of
them so instead he decides to go for
Bishop to e3 a pawn sacrifice Knight
captures on a4 and now Queen to c2 here
we have Bishop to d7 by Carson and now
comes b3 this was the idea and i po had
now cousin has the option of moving the
night but the problem is after Knight c5
rook captures Queen captures and now
Bishop captures on c5 d captures on c5
Queen captures and now cross on his left
sorry an F was left with a very strong
pass to D pawn but cousin finds an
excellent solution to hear a nice
in-between move and he doesn't react to
the B to remove with the by moving the
knight but rather f4 and now he says
okay you capture my knight I'm gonna
capture your bishop or let's say you
move the bishop it should be two now I'm
gonna go efore I'm still not gonna let
you grab the knight and the problem is
you could give up the rook for two
pieces but it still doesn't work if B
captures the Bishop captures and rook
captures now crossing has III and it's a
really powerful attack for black and the
problem is once you move the bishop
let's say Bishop to c3 yes you get a
very nice diagonal but now f3
Bishop has to go back and now after rook
captures an a4 it's a you need to get
two pieces for the rook but your bishop
on each one isn't doing anything so
you're not really
you don't really have two pieces for the
room you have one piece and one piece
that's never gonna see in any light of
day
so after f4 with B captures on a B
captures on a for grabbing the night
cross and grabs the bishop and now comes
a capture son b5 rook captures an a1 by
Carlsen rook captures an a1 and now
Bishop to g5 defending the pawn here and
also opening up the F file for the rook
and Queen - to use as they please
so here the best course of action is f3
just blocking the position not allowing
this rook to use DF file and also not
allowing sorry about that pawn captures
an f2 with check so the f3 is the best
defense for white but here we have b6
nepo decides to go with the active idea
if he wants to get that phone rolling as
soon as possible we have he captures on
f2 with check by crossing King - h1 and
now comes the shock to see it not
allowing the pawn to advance any further
and it's very interesting
rook to e8 doesn't work because just
pawn to f1 of course you bring the Queen
into the game butter up captures rook
captures would check King to g2 and now
of course the deadly Bishop to h3 it's
actually not white who's spinning black
it's black was using this to his own
advantage
King captures you lose the rook and now
at the end of the day well black is just
upper rook and even though you have a
very nice pass pawn here there's really
no way to take advantage of it
so now after Bishop to c8 my cross and
we have looked to f1 by neppo not
allowing any tricks with point to f1 and
now just going to f7 improving the
position with Queen to e2 taking control
of the a6 square you don't want to allow
Bishop to a6 that would kick away the
rook and allow Carson to push the point
all the way so here we have e 4 and what
happens now
well you could capture the pawn but it's
it's such a such a nice line that well
you can capture with the bishop if you
capture with the bush should we get
Bishop to h3 forcing the rook to move or
you would block with the Bishop Bishop
capture screen captures and now just
Queen captures on d5 check wins
right this is one way to go about it the
other idea after efore is Queen captures
on e4 which is the best line of defense
but it's impossible to see it in a rapid
game after Bishop takes six attacking
the rook now quinta east six and
hopefully a white will get counter play
with his with his will for advance pawns
let's say worship captures an f1 Bishop
captures King to a trade now h4 forcing
the bishop to decide where to go after
something like Bishop to c1 Queen
captures and d6 as black decided not to
capture and here white could claim that
the two passports are compensation in
off for the exchange but it's a it's a
pretty you know vicious line for for a
rapid game so neppo decides to go for h4
immediately but this allows Carson to go
for this well it's it's just a
supercomputer move where you want to
call it whatever you want to call it is
just an amazing idea so I will let you
pause the video here and try to find
this brilliant idea
Carlson found and you know it's it's
even enough well not not for nipple but
Carson does get a morphe head here let's
just put that there so there you have it
know that Carson get some morphine head
for this attack and you know feel free
to do it I'm just gonna give you a
couple of seconds for those of you who
were able to do it congratulations you
are an excellent supporter of super
super computer moves and for those who
just want to enjoy the show
Carson's idea is III and now when you
see it of course
you even believe it what's the idea well
the pawn is now guarded by the bishop
here and it's not that nipple can
capture the bishop is it's that nipple
must capture the bishop if he tries
anything but capturing the bishop let's
say 94 then Carson will capture the h4
pawn with the bishop and now G captures
Queen e7 and how do you defend checkmate
here it's a very hard very hard to even
imagine a good defense here you could go
Queen h5 defend the pawn but now look at
for the thread is captures again on h4
the point is guarding the g1 square so
there's really not all that much you can
do Knight of three okay defends it but
now e 2 is coming rook captures on f2 e
1
with Queen night captures and now Queen
captures anyone with Czech rook to f1
and I'll just wrote captures on h4 and
it's all over King Jiwon queen III is
coming you have to block with the rook
now just you grab the Queen and white is
getting checkmate is very quickly
so after this III move nepo decided okay
I can't fill out this so obviously I
must capture the bishop and now comes
the move you had to find to really
believe that this sacrifice is possible
and that is rook to e8 and now the pawn
on e3 is guarded white it doesn't really
have an active move and even though
white is of material the Queen rook and
Bishop are all pretty much stuck here
preventing these pawns from advancing
and now that these report is defended
Crossing is free to find well it's not
some way of winning this position and
it's again it's very easy to blunder
with white for example if again you try
to reintroduce the knight into the game
Bishop to e6 is deadly I remember that
the Queen has to keep an eye on the h5
square you can't allow such a move Queen
captures just Queen here checks better
page three this is checkmate so to
prevent such a scenario nipple tribe
king to h2 it's not really preventing
anything if queen h5 ever happens you
will not be able to block as Bishop also
controls in the h3 square but it is a
start but here across and finds an even
even greater idea so even feel free to
pause the video once again and continue
this attack with black because you know
you already found to two supercomputer
moves find another one to continue this
attack so once again I'll give you a
couple of seconds for those of you who
were able to do it congratulations for
playing in such great style you know
sacrificing piece after piece and for
those if you just want to enjoy the show
Bishop to g4 you have to force the Queen
away from the e2 squared to start
pushing the past pawns
Queen captures on g4 but without
capturing there's not much you can do e
2 is coming whatever you play so Queen
characters and now e 2 and there's a
there's an interesting line of defense
with Knights to d8
just attacking the Queen or forcing rook
to capture and then the Queen would be
able to capture on e2 but it doesn't
work because
Olsen would capture the rook and bring
the knight into the game with the check
and only after captures it would then
recapture here and now it's actually
causing who's up material look for a
bishop and with a much better position
so after E - never tried b7 just trying
to pull that pawn all the way and here
it is possible that calls and blunders
now if you capture with the same line
Knight captures with check Bishop
captures and Queen captures here all of
a sudden you don't have an attack
anymore and white indeed has a knight
and the bishop for a rook so not
something you want to do here cross and
just plays Queen captures on b7 without
even touching the rook he says I'm not
interested in your look I'm just gonna
play pawn to you one bring the Queen
into the game and I'm not gonna give up
my two past points for your rook never
plays rook captures on f2 there's
nothing better
and now just want to e one Queen and
Carson now has two queens but it's it's
not over yet the nipple still has
counter play he goes Queen to a5 he
wants to go night here a night here
block the e-file and create some counter
play so how does Coulson go about this
first he goes Queen to e3 we have looked
to f3 pushing the Queen back with Queen
to e2 and now comes Knights the d4e
maneuvering the night over here with an
attack on the Queen Queen to e5 the
strongest idea either forcing a trade or
capturing the night here so nettle has
to go back Queen g4 defending the knight
and now comes Queen B captures on b5
threatening to win and g5 with Knight to
f5 blocking and again it's quite a
poisonous position seems like Carlson
has everything sorted out he has two
queens but again it's not impossible for
black to blunder either for example if
you try something like Queen e2 efore
just you know let's straight Queens I'm
winning here just look f2 is enough for
nepeta to draw this game and now after
you capture the Queen Bishop captures on
d5 with check King to h8 and now Knight
captures on d6
and you will not be able to escape
perpetual here your look is under attack
once you move at night to f7 is the idea
let's say you try something like rookie
to prevent this rogue from moving hoping
to win it just Knight f7 check you can
even blunder the game King here in a
ditch 6 check
and the queen is lost and even after the
king moves the night defense rook so
white is completely winning now so even
though you have two queens you have to
be careful but you know it's not
something like you can practice no one
practices how to play with two queens
it's just you know even if you have two
queens you know take your time and be
careful
so Queen d2 e six the best move and now
comes Knights to eight Queen to h5 again
hoping that cross and will blunder
something but cousin of course just
wants the trade he's up material he's
not interested in over complicating the
position we have Queen to g4 and now
comes h5 where the Jeep on cannot
capture as the Queen would be lost on g4
Queen to c4 check with d5 by crossing
pushing the Queen back we have Queen B
five and now Queen captures on g5 calmly
grabbing the pawn and here black is
really run a white is really running out
of moves we have Queen to d7 by nipple
and now even h4 where of course you
cannot capture because Queen captures
this G pawn is pinned not possible so
look to f1 and now just H captures and
g3 King to g1 and here across and says
I'm not interested in constantly having
to keep an eye on this g7 pawn move the
knight and you know it's a game over and
but the question is where are we gonna
move it you don't really have any square
for the knight so here
Bishop captures and d5 was played by
nepo with King to h8 and here it was in
this possession after call simply came
to h8 that young pony she resigned the
game and an excellent victory for
Carlsen in in this round two of the
other coup de huaah rapid tournament so
now what if you resign well there's
nothing to do your knight is still under
attack and you can't move it anywhere I
mean this is taken this is taken this is
obviously taken you could try something
like this where now you say okay if
black captures here I'm just gonna
capture the rook with check but then
it's just checkmate Queen e2 e3 check
King g2 or something let's say Queen e2
check now you can either give up the
rook
or go King do you want and then Queen 2h
2 will be checkmate might even use this
as a thumbnail we'll see how it goes but
yeah after this
after the skink 2h8 move a new pony she
resigned and an excellent victory for
mr. Murphy had Carol Carlson he no
longer needs the head as the game is
over but yeah just a brilliant brilliant
game against nipple who I believe still
hasn't lost a game to Causton in
classical or maybe that change but I
don't think he did or maybe did I will
have to check on that one but yeah since
this is rapid the guess that doesn't
matter for that statistics and IIIi
don't think I'll be able to do a video
from round 3 as I'm leaving my hometown
after I make this video so I have
prepared the standings if you're not
interested in the standings you know
close your eyes or close the video so
you don't I don't spoil something for
you but if you are here are the
standings after three rounds of of the
rapid section cross an end ye in tight
first with five points then he core
Nakamura with four points in third place
then for people with three Bingley Ren
Tsuruga Cara conversely so invest in top
all of which two points
maxime beaugeois Grove and Jana pony she
and Grandmaster Bassam I mean with zero
points currently in last place even
though he played a brilliant game in
round one against ding leerin really had
an opportunity to sacrifice a knight on
f7 he didn't take it and then well if
you don't take your opportunity against
ding Lehrer and when it's presented then
you're not gonna beat England it's just
the way it just works so that's the game
I do hope you enjoyed it
do join our chess manga it will be in
the description below if you're
interested if you have a nice idea
I explained everything in the previous
video so everyone's welcome I would like
to thank Julien you subs are they Omid
Mortazavi I wind big understand Robert
Butler and Alessandra inocente for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it as usual you
can check to my previous videos here the
top one of course will be crossings game
against Wesley so from this tournament
so do check that out and yeah I will see
you soon have an excellent rest of your
day